COLT MCANLIS: Hey everybody.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And I'm here to take a
quick look behind the scenes
at some of Google's
data centers.
You see, on March 25,
the Google Cloud Platform
has an exciting event
planned that you're not
going to want to miss.
But before then,
I figured it would
be good to take a look at how
Google works under the hood.
Because when you
talk about Google,
what you're really
talking about is scale.
You see, we serve over 6
billion hours of YouTube video
every single month.
And at the same time,
service 100 billion
searches from Google.
And my personal favorite,
activate 1,000 Android devices
every single minute.
Working at that scale
is no easy task.
We've had to build a
global infrastructure
to handle the load.
Everything from laying fiber
across the Pacific Ocean
to building data
centers that blur
the line between
science, art, and utility
to create something great.
For example, take a look at
this data center in Oregon.
All of these colored pipes
here are not just for show.
Each color details
important information
about the water temperature and
flow direction, which trust me,
is important when you're
trying to track down
a leak in miles of tubing.
And take a look at this
row of servers in Georgia.
These energy-efficient
high-powered LEDs
let us know that everything
is running smoothly
in the server rack.
And this data center
in South Carolina
hosts a three-story
warehouse of machines.
When one of these
bad boys break down,
that automated robot over there,
actually grabs the tape drive
and removes it for you.
The best part about
all this technology
is that we're not
keeping it to ourselves.
Through the power of the
Google Cloud Platform,
you've got access to the
same network, compute,
and storage that runs all
of Google's infrastructure.
And it's offered in a way
that allows you to mix, match,
and combine APIs and services
to fit your application needs.
Which is exactly what the
Snapchat developers did.
You see, they're small
four-person team was
able to leverage the scalable
power of Google App Engine
to make Snapchat one of the
hottest downloads of 2013,
serving over 350
million photos a day.
And consider the Song Pop folks,
who in a few short months,
went from obscurity to serving
2.5 million daily active users,
while only assigning a
single engineer to worry
about performance and uptime.
Which is exactly
what you'd expect
when you're running on the same
exact hardware and software
that powers all of
Google services.
When we're talking
about Cloud offerings,
it's really easy to get
bogged down in the minutia
of key words like site
isolation, or virtual machines,
or load balancing.
And sometimes we forget
the small stuff, the nuts,
the bolts, the solder wires,
the joints, the cooling fans,
the water towers, and yes,
even the colored pipes
that make it all work.
You see, for 15 years we at
Google have been building
beautiful powerful data centers.
And all that power is
now at your command.
Make sure you join the Google
Cloud Platform community
on Google+.
And don't forget to come back
here on March 25 for an event
that you're not going
to want to miss.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Now, go build something great.